[Music]
we are launching a new partnership this
morning with LinkedIn called
work-in-progress we want to explore the
future of jobs and issues facing the
American workforce technology available
today could automate 45% of the job
people are paid to perform across all
occupations by the early 2030s
thirty-eight percent of current jobs in
the United States could be automated
Tony Zucco poll shows us how robots
could hit one industry particularly hard
Tony good morning good morning since at
least the Industrial Revolution
Americans have worried about technology
taking their jobs past inventions though
have ended up creating new jobs not only
destroying the old ones economists worry
that this time may be different to all
the 50 Cent's in Maplewood New Jersey
for 25
Tim Gianni works the register of his
family owned convenience store one city
just as he has since high school thank
you thank you here we know all our
customers my name I I have papers or
candy right I know what they got and
I'll put it right there so that it's
ready for them and it makes them feel
good how do you know oh you just you can
see that when they come in they have
that smile on their face Stella look one
more one day Gianni hopes to pass the
job to a new generation keeping it in
the family four four four or at the very
least I'm loves robot helper keeping it
human other retailers have a very
different dream you can talk to it it
talks back to you can I help you find
something this autonomous multilingual
robot is designed to help customers at
the home improvement chain Lowe's get
their shopping done as quickly as
possible it's basically doing indoor
mapping and it's figuring out where it
is where you are
Kyle Nell is executive director of
Lowe's innovation labs it will hack
actually help you find the thing you're
looking for follow me
the machine is one of 22 that the
company is proudly testing in Northern
California oh my gosh is an autonomous
robot inside of a Louis awesome but what
may look awesome for Lowe's and many of
the nation's other businesses could
spell anxiety for American workers for
decades automation has eaten up more
American jobs than global
trade according to economists who warned
that the job losses may be poised to
accelerate I don't think we've begun to
grapple with what that would mean for
the economy if if these jobs started to
really go away in vast numbers LinkedIn
managing editor chip cutter has been
studying automation
he says cashiers and retail workers may
be hit the hardest this is the single
biggest job category in America that's
correct and it could go away within the
next two decades that's that's the fear
at stop and shop in Bayonne New Jersey
customers can be their own cashiers
scanning bagging and swiping their
credit cards then proceed to the end of
the build to get your item people in
line will ask me oh you use the scanner
do you like it and I tell them like yeah
I recommend you get it because it's a
lot easier to get out of the store a
little quicker at an Amazon concept
store in Seattle sensors allow customers
to shop walk out and pay via a wireless
account that's the technology that a lot
of people say maybe more may more
resemble the future that we're going to
see thank you thanks for coming in teeny
to rap but many of the cashiers and
retail workers of the world aren't
buying it they think the robot
revolution is overblown a robot is just
they're not gonna give you that personal
interaction did you see the other day
the guy credit card though struck out
seventeen ball players martini
that's what people want
juda rubbish gang works down the street
at words bookstore people still like to
talk to somebody I don't think that you
can replicate that and while Kyle Nell
is excited about the future of the Lobot
he says the store has no plans to
replace human workers honestly and truly
the robots are just a support system
what aisle are garage door openers
please select an item below I'm gonna
ask a person yes you prefer that over
ask a person that a stop in shop also
said that the the new scanners are not
going to replace human workers but in
all of these cases the nature of the
work that people are doing it could
change so that the challenge for policy
makers is to get people from the current
jobs retrained into the new ones I'm
with that lady I want to ask a person
what you said today I still like when
you get somebody on the phone I'm happy
oh it's a real person totally totally
they don't go to the bar sometimes it's
hard to find a real person I know you're
right about that or they don't know the
answer retailers are forgetting that
shopping is an experience yeah it's not
just going to buy something you go there
for an experience and right those that
survive are gonna remember that
yeah and that that point of sale person
is also somebody who can upsell you you
know while you're here what about
pairing shoelace yeah well said thank
you so much